[Musique]
il est
un bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver sur public sénat pour suivre
cet après-midi les travaux de la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur la
privatisation des autoroutes les
sénateurs entendent aujourd'hui
dominique de villepin ancien premier
ministre et qui était et bien l'artisan
de cette privatisation des autoroutes
en 2006 il avait défendu cette décision
comme une bonne affaire pour l'état
je vous laisse écouter cette audition
monsieur le président je suis très
heureux d'être devant votre commission
d' enquête sur un sujet aussi important
très heureux parce que cela permet de
dire des choses qui je crois non pas été
dit très heureux ensuite parce qu'il
s'agit du sénat où comme vous le savez
mon père était président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et
des forces armées pendant de nombreuses
années et qu'il a démissionné au jour de
ma nomination comme ministre des
affaires étrangères il y a quinze ans
mon gouvernement est décidé sous
l'autorité du président de la république
la cession par l'état de ses
participations dans les sociétés
concessionnaires qu'il détenait encore
il vous appartient dans le cadre de
votre commission denquête d'apprécier
les conditions dans lesquelles cette
décision était prise je voudrais en
préambule rappelé les quatre questions
qui se posaient à nous à l'époque en
vous demandant de bien vouloir garder à
l'esprit une considération essentielle
le choix 2005 sur les autoroutes ne peut
pas être dissociée de la stratégie
globale choisi par mon gouvernement
première question pourquoi ce choix
d'une cession ce choix est fondée sur
une conviction pour avancer s'adapter se
réformer la france a besoin d'un état
fort ce qui implique une certaine idée
de l'état soumis à une triple exigence
d'unité nationale le défi était de
taille après le 21 avril 2002 une
référendum constitutionnel européen
manqué de consolidation est donc de
rigueur car il faut tenir les cordons de
la bourse de modernisation pour adapter
la france à un monde qui bouge
d'un côté l'entrée de la chine à l'om
c'est en 2001 et de l'autre les efforts
de l'allemagne dans le cadre de l'agenda
cette idée de l'état 5,1 dans une
stratégie économique que j'ai présentées
lors de ma déclaration de politique
générale
avec pour question centrale comment
retrouver des marges de manoeuvre pour
engager la bataille de
emploi investir dans l'avenir et en même
temps se désendetter ma responsabilité
était sans renoncer aux principes
essentiels d'arbitrer entre différentes
exigences c'est à dire préparer l'avenir
par une stratégie industrielle une
politique d'innovation et de
compétitivité ambitieuse mais aussi se
désendetter pour préserver notre
souveraineté avec thierry breton nous
avons mené cette bataille désireux de
créer une prise de conscience collective
c'est le sens du rapport commandé à
michel pébereau comme de l'organisation
de la première conférence des finances
publiques avec les représentants des
collectivités territoriales et les
partenaires sociaux
nous n'avons pas cédé face à bercy
contre le ministère des transports nous
avons pris en compte l'exigence de
réduction de la dette portée par le
ministère de l'économie tout en donnant
au ministère des transports
les moyens d'investir en matière de
transport nous avons voulu aussi être à
l'initiative en 2005 le secteur des
autoroutes étaient arrivés à maturité
mais nous étions pour mener à bien la
modernisation de nos transports face à
une double impasse une impasse de
financement on avait pu croire avec la
création de la fit en 2003 que les
questions de financement des
infrastructures de transport été résolu
malheureusement dans les mois qui ont
suivi la capacité à investir n'était pas
au rendez vous les dividendes
autoroutier affecté à la fidh ne
représentait que 332 millions d'euros en
2005 ce qui ne nous donnait pas de marge
de manoeuvre pour un plan de relance le
budget de la fidh en 2005 n'était que de
1 milliard d'euros est largement
affectés à des investissements déjà
lancé seconde impasse une impasse de
gouvernance dans la gestion des sociétés
d'autoroutes
l'état étant des deux côtés de la table
se retrouve en juge et partie
actionnaires et régulateurs concédant et
concessionnaires pris entre des
exigences contradictoires
ainsi l'état comme les autres
actionnaires des sociétés d'autoroutes
avait intérêt à des dividendes élevés ce
qui n'allait pas dans le sens de la
protection des usagers contre les
hausses de tarifs la cour des comptes a
ainsi souligné dans son rapport de 2008
un certain nombre de dérives ancienne
coupe plus tarifaire non justifiées et
pratiques du foisonnement consistant à
affecter les os aux sections à forte
fyk les administrateurs représentant
l'état au conseil d'administration des
sociétés concessionnaires se trouvait en
outre tiraillé entre les intérêts de
l'état concédant et les intérêts des
sociétés qu'il devait comme tout
administrateur défendre en priorité en
particulier les représentants de l'état
ne pouvait pas participer aux décisions
du conseil d'administration sur les
relations avec l'état notamment sur les
contrats de concession
cela au titre de leur responsabilité
générale de mandataire social devant
agir dans l'intérêt social du
concessionnaire et du régime spécifique
des conventions réglementées
ce n'était évidemment pas le cas des
autres administrateurs et en particulier
des actionnaires privés minoritaires
ainsi du fait de l'alignement sur le
droit commun des sociétés
et la présence d'actionnaires privés à
ses côtés
l'état était en fait devenu un
actionnaire en grande partie passif
soumis aux décisions des actionnaires
minoritaires se contentant d'encaisser
année après année sa part de dividende
on le voit bien à travers ces
difficultés de gouvernance l'état est
pleinement dans son rôle lorsqu'il est
autorités organisatrices
lorsqu'il est concédant en tant
qu'actionnaire de sociétés
concessionnaires
il ne peut jouer qu'un rôle limité dans
ce contexte nous avons jugé nécessaire
de clarifier la position de l'état de
sortir de cette situation d'un état
empêcher financièrement et juridiquement
deuxième grande question quel est le
champ et la portée de notre décision
gouverner c'est choisir ne pas choisir
ses s'endetter c'est pour ces raisons
politiques économiques de politique de
transport que mon gouvernement a décidé
de vendre les parts que l'état français
détenait dans les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes notre
choix a été de valoriser notre
participation dans un secteur mature
pour réinvestir les sommes ainsi
dégagées dans le désendettement et le
financement de nouvelles infrastructures
cette session a rapporté 14 8 milliards
d'euros
nous avons décidé de l'affecter à deux
priorités près de 11 milliards au
désendettement de l'état 11 milliards
d'euros
c'est considérable même rapporter à
notre stock de dettes de l'époque d'un
peu plus de 1000 milliards
je rappelle que l'endettement public a
reculé de 2 points 8 ans par du pays
entre 2005 et 2007 en 2007 la dette
publique ne représentait selon l'insee
que 64 5% du pib contre 67,3 en 2005
avec ce mouvement de baisse le premier
depuis le gouvernement barre nous avons
voulu créer un électrochoc montré qu'il
était possible d'inverser la tendance
pour le reste 4 milliards ont été
affectés à lafitte pour financer les
nouvelles infrastructures plus
respectueuse de l'environnement
en 2005 un audit sur le réseau
ferroviaire le rapport rivier souligner
sa dégradation est l'urgence d'un effort
massif de réinvestissement sur la base
de cet audit avec dominique perben nous
avons mis fin à la logique des
tremblements de la maintenance du réseau
nous en voulons c'est le premier plan de
rénovation de notre réseau national pour
améliorer la qualité des trains du
quotidien
ces décisions étaient attendues et
n'étaient pas possibles avant 2005
en l'absence de ressources suffisantes
au delà de ce réinvestissement massif
dans les trains du quotidien nous avons
engagé la réalisation de quatre lignes à
grande vitesse bordeaux rennes
montpellier rhin rhône inauguré la
première phase du lgv est conclu avec
les collectivités le financement de la
préparation de la deuxième phase tous
ces projets sont aujourd'hui en service
il faut bien rappeler que nous n'avons
pas décidé la privatisation des
autoroutes les autoroutes françaises
font partie du domaine public
contrairement à ce que l'on peut parfois
lire ou entendre l'état en est toujours
le propriétaire à la fin des contrats de
concession les autoroutes ne
disparaîtront pas et demeureront la
propriété des français à la fin des
contrats soit dans les conditions de
2005 à compter de 2028 l'état récupérera
une infrastructure en très bon état
améliorée sur la base des travaux de
rénovation et d'aménagement imposé par
les cahiers des charges de l'état ce que
nous avons cédé ce sont les parts de
l'état dans les sociétés chargée
d'exploiter les concessions
autoroutières cette décision que
beaucoup ont voulu présenter comme une
rupture s'inscrit en réalité dans une
histoire longue marquée par le tournant
de 2001 justifiée par la nécessité
d'ouvrir le secteur autoroutier à la
concurrence avec la fin de l'adossement
trouver de nouveaux financements et de
se conformer au droit européen
le premier choix a été celui de la
concession et du péage en 1955 sous
forme de société d'économie mixte
le second choix dans les années 70 a été
celui de la création de sociétés
totalement privée ce choix fait sous
georges pompidou a été renouvelée sous
lionel jospin avec des concessions
telles que l'a 28 rouen alençon l'a86
ouest ou en 1998 le viaduc de millau
avec jean claude gayssot ministre des
transports le troisième choix
le vrai tournant a eu lieu en 2000 avec
la transformation des sociétés
d'économie mixte en société anonyme de
droit commun et dans la foulée
l'ouverture du capital d'à et c'est fort
mars 2002 souligne mme manjoo ce pas
cette politique a été poursuivi par mon
prédécesseur jean-pierre raffarin avec
l'ouverture du capital d'à p2r en
novembre 2004 et sanef en mars 2005 des
investisseurs privés ont pu ainsi
acquérir selon les sociétés entre 50 et
26% du capital des sociétés toutes les
trois cotés en bourse
pour préparer cette ouverture du capital
des relations entre l'état et ces
sociétés avaient été remises à plat en
deux étapes celle de 1994 sous le
gouvernement d'edouard balladur
avec le regroupement et la
recapitalisation des sociétés ainsi que
la définition de la règle d'évolution
des tarifs sur la base de laquelle la
privatisation a été faite celle de 2001
sous le gouvernement de lionel jospin
qui a consisté à supprimer certains
avantages des sociétés telles que la
garantie de reprise de passif par l'état
en fin de concession
en contrepartie les sociétés ont
bénéficié d'un allongement de la durée
de leur concession ce schéma a été
validé par la commission européenne en
2005 les sociétés concessionnaires était
déjà totalement ou partiellement privé
l'état contrôlait en fait à peine plus
de 50% du secteur -2 62% si on ne prend
pas en compte la société concessionnaire
déjà entièrement privé cofiroute ce que
j'ai décidé en 2005 c'est donc de mener
à son terme le processus déjà engagés et
de cession des parts publiques dans les
sociétés concessionnaires liés à l'êta
par des contrats déjà signés déjà
négocié
m renégocier ce choix marketing
un recul de l'état je ne crois pas car
dans ce cadre clarifier l'état reste le
gardien des intérêts publics au travers
de deux responsabilités celles de
concédant et celle de régulateur l'état
reste propriétaire des autoroutes et
peut assumer pleinement son rôle de
concédant c'est lui qui définit la
taille du réseau le niveau de service
les enjeux de sécurité les principes de
fixation des péages l'état est aussi
régulateur sous la houlette de dominique
perben les contrats de concessions ont
été modifiés pour renforcer les
obligations des concessionnaires dans le
service rendu dans les questions de
sécurité dans la gestion de crise où
l'état reprend toujours la main à
travers les préfets ou encore l'accès du
concédant aux informations
les principales modifications été publié
en amont de la reprise de la remise des
offres finales de façon à être prise en
compte dans les engagements des
candidats
ainsi pour le renforcement des
obligations de publicité et de mise en
concurrence pour la passation des
contrats de travaux pour le renforcement
des obligations d'information du
concédant pour la présence d'un
commissaire du gouvernement aux séances
du conseil d'administration et aux
assemblées générales pour
l'harmonisation et le renforcement des
dispositions concernant la politique
d'exploitation et de sécurité la qualité
du service aux usagers pour
l'augmentation du montant des pénalités
de retard et d'exploitation en cas de
manquement pour la généralisation de la
clause rendant obligatoire un état des
lieux neuf ans avant la fin de la
concession sur les clauses tarifaire
l'état n'a fait aucun cadeau
ce sont les pelouses préexistantes qui
ont été maintenus les règles de fixation
des péages sont rigoureusement les mêmes
que celles définies antérieurement en
pratique les péages ont semble-t-il
augmenté moins vite
avant 2005 qu'après nous n'avons pas
changé ses règles tarifaires pour
changer la durée et les péages des
concessions il aurait fallu modifier les
contrats ces contrats ne peuvent pas
être modifié unilatéralement par l'état
toute modification suppose un accord
avec les sociétés concessionnaires nous
l'avons vu en 2015 lors de la tentative
du gouvernement de l'époque de décidé un
gel des péages conduisant à l'impasse
dans un cadre comptable qui contractuels
l'état ne peut pas passer en force
d'autant que pour l'examen de tout
projet de modification les
administrateurs de l'état comme je
l'indiquais sont légalement au
liger de se déporter laissant ainsi les
autres administrateurs seules en
position de décision ceci est notamment
les minoritaires n'aurait jamais accepté
des clauses amputant substantiellement
la valeur des sociétés
ces contraintes ont été clairement
rappelé par le ministre d'état jean
louis borloo dans son rapport dans sa
réponse au rapport de 2008 de la cour
des comptes
je le cite les mandataires sociaux ne
peuvent conclure un avenant ou un
contrat d'entreprise avec l'état qu'à la
condition qu'il soit conforme à
l'intérêt social de l'entreprise compte
tenu de l'impact des clauses tarifaires
sur les revenus futurs des sociétés leur
durcissement est à l'évidence difficile
à faire accepter que l'entreprise soit
public ou privé ne change rien à la
responsabilité des mandataires sociaux
telle qu'elle est par exemple sanctionné
par l'article l 242 6 du code du
commerce
article je le rappelle qui prévoit des
sanctions pénales
troisième grande question quels ont été
les modalités de l'opération
d'abord la procédure politique j'ai
présenté le cap retenu 8 juin 2005 au
parlement lors du discours de politique
générale ce discours a été suivi d'un
vote de confiance la décision
d'autoriser le transfert des parts de
l'état dans les sociétés d'autoroutes et
d'une décision que j'ai prise en plein
accord bien sûr avec jacques chirac par
décret des 2 février 16 février et 8
mars 2006 nous avons sollicité le
conseil d'état sur la procédure à suivre
celui ci a rendu un avis en assemblée
générale confirmant la régularité de la
procédure retenue par le gouvernement le
conseil d'état nous a en particulier
confirmé que la poursuite de la cession
des parts ne nécessitait pas de vote du
parlement
notamment parce qu'il n'y avait pas
contrairement par exemple au projet
d'ouverture du capital d'adp épais de
transfert du domaine public
je rappelle pour autant qu'avant la
cession effective des parts de l'état
le parlement a été saisi du projet de
loi de finances pour 2006 dans lequel
été retracé les conséquences de la vente
de nos participations
le parlement a adopté la loi de finances
avec l'affectation des recettes de
cession partant de là l'état s'est mis
en bon ordre de marche au niveau
gouvernement du gouvernement avec
l'action concertée de thierry breton aux
ministres de l'économie et de dominique
perben ministre dés transports au niveau
des services de l'état avec l'action de
l'agencé des participations de l'état
chargés de
le thé le processus de privatisation la
pe s'entoure pour ses opérations de
conseil financier et juridique de haut
niveau la dgitm de son côté a pleinement
joué son rôle dans les cahiers des
charges et la révision des clauses
contractuelles qui pouvait l'être
deuxièmement la procédure technique la
procédure retenue est celle qui donne le
plus de poids aux intérêts de l'état
sachant que l'état est faible lorsqu'ils
négocient de gré à gré et qu'il est fort
lorsqu'il lance un appel d'offres ouvert
et concurrentiel pour obtenir le
meilleur prix nous avons lancé un appel
d'offres ouvert et compétitif auquel ont
participé 18 candidats français et
étrangers majoritairement je le souligne
des opérateurs industriels de premier
rang et non des fonds c'est le moyen le
plus efficace pour obtenir le meilleur
prix enfin nous avons fait le choix
d'une gouvernance apportant toutes les
garanties nécessaires la mise en oeuvre
de notre décision s'est faite sous le
contrôle de plusieurs autorités nous y
reviendrons plus en détail si vous le
souhaitez le conseil de la concurrence
la commission des participations et des
transferts
la commission européenne par ailleurs
nous avons aussi décidé pour rendre la
procédure irréprochable de nommer jean
louis faure ancien secrétaire général de
la commission bancaire pour veiller au
bon déroulement de la procédure
enfin quatrième question des intérêts de
l'état ont-ils été bien préservés
concernant les intérêts de l'état nous
avons d'abord cherché à garantir à juste
prix quels sont les repères chiffrés
réunis par l' agence de participation de
l'état et qui ont été partagés à
l'époque au sein de l'état lorsque nous
avons lancé le processus
si on regarde le cours de bourse des
trois sociétés concernées les
participations de l'état valait 11 5
milliards d'euros avant que j'annonce
leur vente le 8 juin 2005 le rapport du
député hervé mariton réalisé avant cette
annonce avait évalué entre 10 et 12
milliards la valeur des participations
la commission des participations et des
transferts a quant à elle estimé la
valeur a minima kan devait attendre
l'état à 12,8 milliards d'euros quel
prix avons-nous obtenus nous en avons
obtenu 14,8 milliards d'euros soit 30
pour cent de mieux que le dernier cours
de bourse
c'est un résultat qui était dans la
fourchette haute de nos attentes et des
modèles financiers d'évaluation des
sociétés concernées
compte tenu de la part des autres
actionnaires cela donne une valeur
totale des sociétés de 22 24 milliards
de
ce chiffre figure en note de bas de page
ou rapport de la cour des comptes de
2009 qui précise la valeur globale des
7000 km d'autoroutes public dont la
concession a été privatisée en 2006 qui
a été estimé à 24 milliards d'euros et
leur cession à rapporter 14 8 milliards
d'euros à l'état je souligne le risque
de malentendu et j'insiste sur le terme
malentendus liés à l'interprétation du
chiffre de la cour des comptes à
l'origine de beaucoup de polémiques 24
milliards d'euros
c'est la valeur de 100 % des parts des
trois sociétés 14,8 milliards c'est la
valeur des parts détenues par l'état
soit en moyenne 61 7%
ces deux chiffres ne se contredisent
donc en rien s'agissant de la plus
grosse des trois sociétés asf dont
l'état ne détenait plus que 50% du
capital suite à sa mise sur le marché au
prix de 24 euros par action sous le
gouvernement de lionel jospin
nous avons obtenu 51 euros par action
ainsi nous avons vendu le solde de la
participation de l'état dans les
sociétés concessionnaires au mieux de
leur valeur à l'époque et je souligne
deux points essentiels
ce sont les soumissionnaires qui propose
dans le cadre d'une procédure
compétitive est ouverte le prix
d'acquisition selon des méthodes
classiques d' évaluation multicritères
et c'est la commission des
participations et transferts et el sol
seulement qui valide que ces prix sont
au dessus du seuil qui garantit
parfaitement les intérêts de l'état
elle valide donc implicitement le juste
prix et ses avis sont publiques
votre commission peut accéder à toutes
ces données pour établir de façon
transparente
comment les sociétés ont été valorisés
ainsi nous avons vendu le solde de la
participation de l'état dans les
sociétés concessionnaires au mieux de
leur valeur à l'époque je souligne que
l' agence des participations de l'état a
conservé forcément toutes ces données
votre commission peut les trouver assez
facilement par dans partant de là les
intérêts de l'état ont été prises en
compte
à chaque étape premier constat l'état a
bien tenu ses promesses en affectant le
produit de la vente au désendettement et
à l'investissement
deuxième constat au delà de la vente
initiale l'état continue de percevoir
des taxes importantes assis sur les
péages essentiellement la tva
des taxes spécifiques comme la redevance
domaniale et la taxe d'aménagement du
territoire affecté à la fit et l'impôt
sur les sociétés c'est au total de
l'ordre de 5 milliards que l'état
encaisse annuellement soit plus de 40 %
des belges
troisième constat la qualité du service
est assuré et on s'accorde à reconnaître
que nos autoroutes sont parmi les
meilleurs d'europe et du monde
quatrième constat l'état récupérera la
fin des concessions une infrastructure
autoroutière en bon état à améliorer les
travaux réalisés par les
concessionnaires
on voit d'ailleurs que le réseau routier
et autoroutier placé sous la
responsabilité directe de l'état vieilli
et connaît des problèmes d'entretien
important je pense en particulier au
réseau francilien
aujourd'hui le patrimoine autoroutier
français concédé est en meilleur état
faut-il le rappeler que le patrimoine
routier restait sous la gestion
opérationnelle public
en conclusion je voudrais formulé trois
voeux devant notre commission d'abord ne
pas céder aux chronos centrisme c'est à
dire à ne pas juger avec les critères
d'aujourd'hui une décision prise à une
date antérieure soin de bien prendre en
compte les paramètres qui étaient les
nôtres quand la décision a été prise ne
pas perdre de vue que les concessions
sont des contrats de long terme qu'il
faudra évaluer à leur terme et que les
risques et imprévu ne doivent pas être
sous-estimés enfin le choix de 2005 ne
peut être dissociée de la stratégie
globale choisi par mon gouvernement
comme vous le voyez mon gouvernement n'a
pas bradé les bijoux de famille
pas plus qu'il n'a tuer la poule aux
oeufs d'or bien au contraire la période
2005 2007 a été une période où la france
grâce aux marges de manoeuvre dégagées a
su améliorer ses performances
économiques
qu'ils s'agissent de la baisse du
chômage de la réduction des déficits ou
de la baisse de la dette
nous avons obtenu dans cette période en
fin du mandat de jacques chirac
les meilleurs résultats économiques des
trente dernières années
en témoigne tout particulièrement la
comparaison avec l'allemagne puisque
notre bilan économique et financier
était encore à cette date en 2007 al
avantage de la france je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur premier ministre
de votre propos étayés avec des
précisions
avait qualifié de remarquable mais je
pense que notre rapporteur va aux ordres
de vente des demandes et des précisions
complémentaires mais tout simplement
pour rappeler qu'ici il n'est pas du
tout question de jus de jugement des
décisions prises mais que nous sommes ni
des concessions autoroutières ni du
modèle concessif il n'est pas de notre
propos mais en tous les cas de faire des
propositions à l'état pour renforcer son
son rôle dans la négociation et on dit
un peu dans notre commission
rééquilibrer le rapport de force entre
les sociétés autoroutières et les
représentants de l'état qui travaillent
à leurs côtés
monsieur j'ai fait un petit lapsus
monsieur le président si vous permettez
gg je me suis trompé
la vérité c'est que les péages ont
augmenté moins vite à moins de budget le
sac qu'avant oui j'avais noté voilà
sinon alors que je corrige ce petit
lapsus qui vous permet c'est corrigé ce
sera corrigé au au compte rendu
vous êtes gentil monsieur le rapporteur
et merci monsieur le président de ce
prêt ministre sur ce dernier point juste
une précision quand même il faut il faut
ça augmenté moins vite mais aussi par
rapport à l'inflation qui était moins
important c'est à ce moment là sur cette
période là parce que quand on compare
l'augmentation des tarifs par rapport à
l'inflation sur la période de
pourcentage par contre de différence est
un peu plus supérieur donc voila mais
c'est pour préciser un petit peu les
choses sur ce plan-là je vous remercie
monsieur le premier d'abord d'avoir tenu
à peu près les délais à une minute près
mais c'est quand même c'est quand même
remarquable et d'avoir excellemment bien
préparer votre audition donc vous nous
avez rappelé pas mal de choses le
contexte ce qui est important
effectivement dans une décision la
politique était suivi les soirs
j'entends tous à la régularité de la
procédure
tous âges entend parfaitement et vous
avez très bien défendu contre votre
action beau décision et alors j'ai
plusieurs questions d'abord
quand
on choisi de transformer les sem en fait
ça en 2001 c'est pas vous ces jeunes et
j'ose pas et il ouvre à cette époque là
le capital de sf est ce que vous trouvez
que c'est une bonne décision
est-ce que vous l'auriez prise qu'est ce
qui selon vous justifier cette décision
de commencer à mettre 20 % du capital
sur le marché en tout cas de céder ses
20% de capital à l'époque ensuite dans
la procédure de privatisation
vous avez bien rappeler les chiffres 14
milliards 8
touché par l'état mais pour les
participations qui lui restait à ce
moment là et finalement 24 milliards
payés parler parce que avant 2001 l'état
était à travers différentes organismes
aux autres était propriétaire à 100%
d'accord sauf de cofiroute et cofiroute
ne rentrait pas dans les privatisations
en dehors de cofiroute l'état avant 2001
était à 100%
finalement entre 2001 et 2006 on dépense
colle les actionnaires pour se rendre
propriétaire de sf dépensera 1 4
milliard et l'état touchent finalement 4
14 milliards 8
donc c'est clair qu'il ya quand même une
différence qui vient selon moi de la
procédure suivie à la fois d'ouverture
des 20% du capital de sf par lionel
jospin en 2001 et aussi par la procédure
suivie pour la mise sur le marché du
reste des titres puisque ça a été fait
en deux temps avec une première partie
qui est qui et partira cours de bourse à
ses plus faibles et ensuite une
augmentation du cours de bourse
et puis sur un des lots justement le lot
qui finalement ramené à 20 600
concurrence si vous avez cité qu'il y
avait 18 18 groupes mais finalement sur
un des lots et sans une plus important
finalement il avait qu'un seul
concurrent et ce concurrent a fait une
offre qui était moins élevé par rapport
au prix minimum fixé que celui des deux
autres lots qui était avec plus de
concurrence donc ça montre quand même
qu'il ya eu sans doute quand même un
petit problème de procédure qui est pas
forcément lié aux décisions de votre
gouvernement je n'en sais rien mais
j'aimerais que vous nous disiez un peu
ce que vous en pensez
par rapport à cela troisième question
est-ce que alors plus d'ailleurs en 2001
au moment de la transformation des décès
mauressac peut-être après mais est-ce
que à ce moment là il n'était pas
souhaitable avant
de céder au privé de m c ces contrats et
ses sociétés en en vente
est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas été
souhaitable de revoir quand même et de
mettre à jour les contrats cds contrats
datait de plusieurs dizaines d'années
et visiblement alors c'est les abeilles
bornes qui les a traité de monstre
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas on avait
des contrats qui auraient sans doute
mérité un toilettage est ce que ça a été
un sujet qui a été évoqué à l'époque
est ce que finalement vous étiez assez
pressé vous avez dit on n'a pas le temps
de le faire
ou est-ce que c'est simplement en toute
connaissance de cause vous ai dit c'est
pas la peine de le faire moi j'aimerais
comprendre ça et puis ce qui intéresse
pas mal d'autres commissions c'est quand
même l'avenir le passé c'est bien mais
c'est passé vous avez bien défendez
votre votre bilan et vos actions
maintenant qu'est ce que vous feriez
aujourd'hui si vous étiez encore premier
ministre et est ce que sur le sujet vous
pensez qu'il y aurait des choses à faire
pour préparer la fin des concessions
sachant qu'il ya déjà eu des évolutions
quand même sensible en 2015
est ce que il y a des choses
complémentaires que vous feriez que
préconiseriez pour que l'état soit
peut-être un petit peu plus fort dans la
négociation merci monsieur le rapporteur
donc c'est le premier ministre merci à
vous le rapporteur général concernant la
première question le choix d'ouvrir le
capital d'edf et d'une manière générale
le tournant de 2001 je crois qu'il faut
être juste et se rappeler que dans cette
période il y avait un choix qui était
aiguillonner plus ou moins contraint à
la fois la nécessité de se conformer aux
exigences de la commission européenne ce
a pesé lourd à la fois la nécessité pour
des raisons de besoins financiers de
s'ouvrir aux sociétés non mais mais mais
la commission européenne était favorable
à l'ouverture à la concurrence donc
c'était un argument important dans le
fait de modifier
situation qui était là nous nous
retrouvions par rapport aux autres
sociétés dans le cadre européen
un petit peu comme un cas isolé donc il
ya une exigence d'ouverture du cadre des
concessions au privé il y avait une
exigence de mise en conformité
concernant notamment la durée des
concessions nous étions obligés de
passer par l'aval de la commission
européenne et il y avait une troisième
exigence qui est l alignement sur le
droit commun des sociétés d'autoroutes
l'alignement sur le droit commun
l'alignement sur le droit des sociétés
anonymes
donc il y avait là une obligation nous
aurions plus et peut-être aurait-il
fallu le faire à cette époque-là revoir
le cahier des charges revoir les les
les contrats eux mêmes quand nous
héritons de la situation en 2005-2006
j'allais dire c'est presque trop tard
puisque nous sommes nous sommes dans des
sociétés qui sont ouvertes aux
minoritaires et qui nous place dans la
situation que j'ai essayé de pas tout
pas tout n'était pas encore tout
c'était tout tout était ouverte aux
minoritaires et c'est ce que j'ai voulu
indiquer et qui me paraît important
c'est le seul le dispositif qui régit
serre en particulier les conventions
réglementées et le dispositif
d'obligation pour les représentants de
ces sociétés en tant que mandataire
social de respecter l'intérêt des
actionnaires et l'intérêt de
l'entreprise
donc vous voyez bien c'est une notion
qui est souvent peu pris en compte c'est
que mettions pas libre complètement de
nos choix à cette époque compte tenu du
droit des sociétés compte tenu du
contexte dans lequel nous agissions donc
on veut penser qu'il aurait suffi 2 les
choses n'étaient pas si simple après
2001 monsieur promise pour que je
comprenne bien la commission européenne
donc souhaité qu'il y ait dans les
sociétés
concessionnaire à l'époque qui étaient
publics de la concurrence 1
et ça veut dire qu' il n'y avait pas
d'autres pays européens qui avaient le
même système de société
public d'en laisser venir dans mon
souvenir il y avait un mouvement qui
s'organisait au sein de l'europe et qui
posait problème
voilà qui poussait dans son cela donc le
contexte était bien trois mouvements en
2001 à la fois le mouvement dans le sens
de l'ouverture au privé
le mouvement dans le sens de l'ouverture
à la concurrence l'alignement sur le
droit des sociétés qui créent en termes
de gouvernance des sociétés des
contraintes importantes et pour ce qui
est de la contrepartie qui a été donnée
à certaines sociétés d'allongement de la
durée
il fallait l'accord de la commission
européenne ce qui a été donné à cette
époque
donc on est dans un système qui est
relativement verrouillé et sur lequel
nous n'avons pas en 2005-2006 de marge
de manoeuvre importante parce que nous
nous retrouvons dans le cadre de conseil
d'administration où nous avons une
position qui est difficile à faire
entendre puisque les administrateurs de
l'état doive se déporter dans un grand
nombre de cas dès lors on parle
notamment de la question des tarifs et
de la durée et dès lors que les
différents mandataires sociaux sont
censés représenter l'intérêt général des
entreprises
donc nous ne sommes pas en mesure de
faire exactement ce que nous aurions
souhaité faire ou voulu faire à ce
moment là alors deuxième élément sur la
procédure concernant vinci un seul
concurrent
c'est le principe de tout appel d'offres
on est dans un appel d'offres
tout ceci se passe complètement en
dehors de toute interférence et de toute
volonté politique on a une procédure
définie par l' agence des participations
la commission nationale des
participations et des transferts
tout ceci se fait donc sous le contrôle
de ces commissions qui sont
indépendantes et qui vérifie la
conformité de cela heureusement le
pouvoir politique n'a pas le moyen de
rentrer dans ces débats et ça se fait en
plus avec les avis prix julie cité tout
à l'heure le conseil de la concurrence
et l'ensemble des différentes instances
qui se sont prononcés sur ce débat alors
concernant ceux ci étant excusez moi
monsieur promis quand on fait des appels
d'offres aux autres on peut les déclarer
infructueux si on considère qu'il n'y a
pas eu
des réponses satisfaisantes ou
suffisamment de concurrence à un moment
donné sur les trois lots on aurait très
bien pu se dire on a qu'une seule
réponse
on considère qu'au remets en question en
question est en jeu selon l'ars sachant
qu'on peut attribuer les autres monsieur
rapporte en général le prix minimum qui
avait été donné par la commission des
participations et des transferts était
de 47 euros et nous avons obtenu 51 donc
nous sommes tout à fait dans les clous
on peut pas faire n'importe quoi ce sont
des procédures qui ont leurs règles et
qui ont été entièrement respectée de ce
point de vue là d'ailleurs il ya un
certain nombre de d'idées reçues qui
pèse lourdement sur ces questions je
pense en particulier en ce qui concerne
le prix puisque vous évoquez le prix la
cour des comptes à l'époque en 2008 2009
nous avait reproché de ne pas avoir mis
suffisamment de conseil autour de la
table on n'aurait eu qu'un seul banquier
en fait nous avons eu à l'époque deux
banquiers je le rappelle goldman sachs
et bnp paribas
on nous a reproché un prix trop bas j'ai
entendu devant votre commission là le
plaidoyer qui a été fait par gilles
carez sur le fait que le prix aurait été
trop bas et qu'il aurait fait travailler
à l'époque le commissariat au plan qui
aurait défendu un prix très supérieur à
celui qui était obtenue il faut se
rappeler ce que dit le conseil d'état
dans sa décision du 27 septembre 2006
par lequel il a rejeté le moyen avancé
parfois s'emballe françois bayrou et
deux associations de défense des usagers
qui soutenaient que la valeur minimale
de cession avait été sous-évalué par la
commission des participations notamment
du fait d'un taux d'actualisation
supérieur à celui préconisé par le
commissariat général du plan
le conseil d'état a démontré qu
augmenter pour prendre en compte
l'inflation et la légitime prise de
risque le taux d'actualisation suggéré
par le plan aurait en réalité conduit à
une valeur des titres inférieure à celle
évaluée par la commission des
participations et conseil d'état a par
ailleurs souligné que la valorisation
retenue était supérieur tant au cours de
bourse constatés sur les mois ayant
précédé des transferts cpt aux
estimations effectuées par les experts
donc vous voyez que les deux sources de
polémiques et j'y reviendrai peut-être
tout à l'heure si vous me le permettez
les deux sources majeures de polémique
sur ce dossier dans les années qui ont
suivi 2005 2006
concernant le prix a pris trop faible et
un taux d'actualisation qui aurait était
trop élevé ne correspondent pas à la
réalité
donc les polémiques s'agrègent sur des
choses qui ne correspondent pas à la
réalité et ça à partir de là
effectivement l'opinion publique ne
comprend pas et à la de sentiment qu'on
a bradé les intérêts de l'état cela
cela n'a pas été le cas je le précise il
ya un autre argument qu'a pris la cour
des comptes sur la vente et qui nous a
été reproché à l'époque c'est l'idée que
nous aurions obtenu un meilleur prix si
nous avions au préalable désendetter les
sociétés vous savez que c'est de l'ordre
de 18 à 20 milliards de l'endettement
que les sociétés privées ont repris mais
cela n'était ni possible ni souhaitable
il aurait fallu injecter alors plus de
fonds publics et pour quels bénéfices
les actionnaires privés ont fait le
contraire en augmentant le levier
financier des sociétés et donc leur
endettement
donc il ya un certain nombre d'idées
reçues de serpent de mer qui circulent
comme cela sur ces dossiers qui mérite à
mon sens et je vous en remercie d'être
corrigés alors pour l'avenir vaste
vaste sujet je crois que la première
règle qui me paraît important c'est la
nécessité pour l'état de renforcer sa
capacité de régulation économique des
monopoles naturels et je souscris
pleinement à ce que vient de dire
ségolène royal devant votre commission
il n'y a pas de fatalité la question
d'ailleurs en 2006 2008 ne se posait pas
du tout dans les termes où les choses se
pose depuis avec le paquet vert de 2010
avec le plan de relance autoroutier de
corrigé par le plan d'investissement de
donc les choses se présentent
aujourd'hui différemment mais dans les
années qui ont suivi la privatisation
des sociétés l'état disposait de tous
les moyens pour se faire respecter et la
citation que j'ai donnée de jean louis
borloo qui est dans le rapport de la
cour des comptes montre bien que nous
avons la capacité administrative mais
bien sûr dès lors que nous avons aussi
la capacité et la volonté politique et
ségolène royal a eu raison de dire
malheureusement trop souvent dans ces
années là
la volonté politique a pu faire défaut
mais face à trois sociétés
concessionnaires ou ne m'expliquerai pas
comment l'état n'est pas capable
d'assurer sa fonction des régulateurs
alors qu'il serait un formidable
mainteneur et vous ne m'expliquerai pas
comme en revenant et remettant ces
sociétés dans le giron public tout à
coup tous les problèmes disparaîtrait
c'est totalement absurde si l'état n'est
pas capable est un bon régulateur par
définition il ne sera pas un bon
maintenant donc je crois que de ce point
de vue il faut remettre les pendules à
l'heure mais une fois de plus le sujet
des autoroutes en france c'est bien plus
que le sujet les autoroutes
c'est un sujet qui a valeur symbolique
une valeur politique et qui trop souvent
a été traitée au sein des ministères de
façon technique il ya un rapport de
force avec les sociétés d'autoroutes
nous les connaissons mais ça existe dans
tous les grands secteurs de l'état 1
quand l'état discute avec eux les
sociétés d'automobiles quand il discute
avec les sociétés aéronautiques
c'est pas dans les ministères techniques
que sas arbitres et ben y'a pas de
raison que les autoroutes ce soit la
sous direction chargée du réseau qui se
retrouve en première ligne devant des
sociétés d'autoroutes ça me paraît un
élément important est un élément à
corriger dans l'avenir
par ailleurs je crois que la cour des
comptes le conseil de la concurrence
l'autorité de régulation des transports
ont éclairé un certain nombre de voies
de renforcement de la fonction de
régulation qui me paraissent importantes
et je retiendrai trois idées la première
idée c'est le haut niveau de compétence
et de professionnalisme requis beaucoup
de voeux ceux qui se sont présentés
devant la commission lors appelé il faut
une compétence technique il faut une
compétence juridique gilles de robien eu
raison de le dire il faut être capable
et armes égales de de capacités face aux
sociétés d'autoroutes ya une deuxième
exigence que l'exigence de transparence
elle n'a pas toujours existé tout au
long des années elle me paraît essentiel
dans la conduite de la régulation
notamment sur l'information des
autorités publiques et la motivation des
décisions dans le mandat qu'avaient
dominique perben en 2005 2006 pour
durcir les atouts de l'état au sein
des cahiers des charges il y avait cette
exigence de transparence et
d'information avec des clauses
extrêmement exigeante qui n'ont
malheureusement pas été appliquée dans
les années qui ont suivi une troisième
nécessité c'est une pratique rigoureuse
dans la gestion des contrats et de leurs
avenants en particulier en ce qui
concerne la question des allégements des
concessions à mon sens là où ne parlons
pas de la même chose et là où les
polémiques
pardon oui allongement oui absolument
là où nous parlons pas de la même chose
quand le dossier est traité en 2006 et
aujourd'hui c'est qu'évidemment la durée
ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
on a beaucoup cédé à travers
l'allongement des concessions et
malheureusement c'est allongement ne
sont pas soumis à une mise en
concurrence alors que celle ci est
souvent nécessaire pour la protection
des intérêts de l'état
la rta mis en oeuvre utilement ce
principe de rigueur dans la définition
des investissements et leurs modalités
de prise en compte dans les avenants
autoroutier issus du plan de relance
2015 je crois que c'est une bonne chose
mais cette dérive où l'état parce qu'il
n'est pas capable de trouver l'argent
nécessaire
hachette en quelque sorte par du temps
les travaux qui doivent être faites sans
toujours vérifier ségolène royal l'a
redit sans toujours vérifier que ces
travaux ne sont pas déjà prévu dans son
cahier des charges de ce point de vue là
l'état régulateur s'est montré faible et
cet allongement de durée de concession a
complètement modifié le regard que nous
portons sur ces concessions parfois même
perverti et je pense que cela a été une
erreur
je le redis tout à l'heure quand nous
avons signé en 2006 les premières
fin de concession c'était 2027
aujourd'hui on parle de durée beaucoup
beaucoup plus longue
ce n'est donc oui ce n'est donc plus du
tout la même chose
je crois que dans un monde qui bouge
extrêmement vite et on le voit avec ce
qu'on avait oubliés y compris pour les
concessionnaires il ya des risques
importants on l'a vu avec la crise de
2008 2009
on le voit aujourd'hui avec la crise
sanitaire série ce qu'ils sont majeurs
et ils ont peut-être vocation à
s'amplifier dans les prochaines années
et dans ce contexte là on n'a pas
intéressant couleau
deux rendez-vous sérieuse et bien prévu
100 des durée raisonnable à se lancer
dans une aventure au long cours qui
forcément joue contre les intérêts de
l'état
merci monsieur le premier ministre alors
pour revenir un peu en 2006 voir en 2001
les contrats pour une précision que le
rapporte à une caisse une question du
rapporteur sur les contrats qui ont
couru finalement de 2006 les contrats
précédents ont été maintenues en l'état
et il n'y a pas eu de révision je suis
assez fidèle à la question que tu
souhaites poser non mais j'ai entendu la
réponse a été apporté la réponse assez
j'ai pas entendu parler ici vous comment
j'ai entendu je n'ai entendu dans les
propos de ce premier ministre j'ai
entendu effectivement que ces contrats
auraient dû sans doute être révisée au
moment où c'était une société commune
mixte et qu' il y avait soit avant la
ligne mantes 2001 avant avant
l'avènement après ben laden est nominé
puisqu'il y avait des actionnaires
minoritaires mais privé et que cette
occasion là c'était beaucoup plus ni dès
lors qu'il ya des minoritaires le droit
des minoritaires et le droit des
sociétés fait qu'elles sont dans une
situation où l'état ne peut plus décider
seul je retire va devant de précision le
premier ministre merci monsieur le
rapporteur donc des collègues ont
demandé la parole de céder la parole à
dominique de legge et ensuite à jérôme
bascher devait porter monsieur premier
ministre merci de nous avoir éclairé et
surtout d'avoir démontré que ce sujet
était complet que je reprends vos termes
besoin de transparence valeur symbolique
politique et vous avez employé le mot
fait repentent mer ce dossier moi ma
question sur l'aspect politique et la
manière dont les parlementaires ont été
associés à ces petits
d'un strict point formel vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure c'est au détour
d'une haute finance n'estimez vous pas
qu il eût été souhaitable que le pain
bien comment on vote la loi de finances
dans des délais de procédure
particulière très encadrée avec eux que
nous puissions pas toucher à l'équilibré
je ne pensez vous pas qu'il eût été
souhaitable d'avoir un débat dans un
autre cadre
et si vous posez la question je pense
que nous avons avec adp
et là des jeux où on nous l'a vendu dans
le cadre d'un texte de 220 arctique la
loi pâté en nous disant tandem avec un
jour pauvreté qu'est cadeaux et donc de
tels sujets puisse apparaître comme
beaucoup de tels sujets n'apparaissent
pas avoir étudié dans toute la
transparence nécessaire et suffisante et
donc ma question ce qu'il n'aurait pas
été préférable
un peu différemment le parlement merci
ce premier ministre merci monsieur le
sénateur je crois que on peut débattre à
l'infini sur ce qui aurait été mieux le
choix que nous avons fait n'oubliez pas
j'arrive comme premier ministre au
lendemain de l'échec du référendum
européen je dispose d'une vingtaine de
mois actifs pour agir et donc
l'ambition du premier ministre comme
l'ambition de l'époque j'étais comme
l'ambition de jacques chirac c'est de
refaire de refaire un certain nombre de
choses de dégager des marges de
manoeuvre et pour dégager des marges de
manoeuvre amamou l'investissement public
était complètement bloquée un moment où
il était difficile d'imaginer le moindre
blanc pour revitaliser la croissance est
bien en l'absence de marge de manoeuvre
on les crée donc le temps est important
je vous rappelle par ailleurs que ce
n'est pas la première fois que le
capital de sociétés est ouvert c'est la
quatrième fois
lionel jospin prend une décision
deux fois après en 2002 et 2005 début
2005 2003 et début 2005 jean-pierre
raffarin poursuit dans ce sens et je
suis donc le quatrième le quatrième
mouvement de mise sur le marché de
cession sur le marché d'une partie du
capital des sociétés d'autoroutes alors
évidemment j'ai le grand mérite ou le
grand défaut d'être celui qui met ce qui
reste sur le marché donc ça a une valeur
symbolique je le reconnai volontier mais
c'est le même exercice
c'est le même exercice et dans ce
contexte là je rappelle que le
parallélisme des formes vous savez que
c'est un élément auquel nous tenons dans
notre pays parce que nous aimons le
droit et nous avons aussi les repères le
parallélisme des formes fait que j'ai
pratiqué la même règle que celle qui
avait été faite par mes prédécesseurs et
donc j'ai décidé par décret tout en
veillant à ce que la représentation
nationale puisse être saisi par la loi
de finances certes mais aussi au travers
de deux débats un ou sénat et l'autre à
l'assemblée nationale où chacun a pu
s'exprimer sur ces sujets et dire ce
qu'il avait à dire
donc vous avez tout à fait raison quand
faut-il arrêter la pendule à partir de
quel moment et ont épuisé un sujet et à
partir de quand il faut agir alors
tantôt l'état se voit reprocher de ne
pas agir assez vite et assez bien et de
temps en temps on lui reproche a
posteriori
d'avoir agi de façon précipitée c'est un
reproche qui m'a souvent été fait mais
en l'occurrence je crois qu'il faut
savoir arbitrer et cet arbitrage il a
été fait au vu de ce que nous pensons et
c'est pour ça que j'ai placé cette
audition sous l'égide de ce qu'était la
stratégie de mon gouvernement je dis
bien c'est une décision stratégique
on n'a pas et c'est là où je voudrais
pas qu'il y ait dans vos esprits de
malentendus j'ai entendu et gilles de
robien est quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup
il a été mon ministre de l'éducation et
c'est quelqu'un de remarquable mais il a
fait état de ces deux rencontres avec
bercy nous trompons pas sur ses
rencontres avec bercy
ce sont les rencontres habituelles de
tout ministre technique avec le ministre
qui tient les cordons de la bourse
et que bercy cherche à obtenir davantage
d'un ministre dans ce contexte là qu'un
mini se prépare c'est ce que j'ai vécu
communiste de l'intérieur c'est ce que
j'ai vécu communiste affaires étrangères
mais nous n'étions pas du tout dans ce
débat là on est dans quelque chose de
tout à fait différent en 2005
on est dans une stratégie qui requiert
des marges de manoeuvre et qui passe par
un arbitrage entre faut-il ne rien
changer
ou faut-il changer quelque chose pour
disposer de marges de manoeuvre qui
permettent de remettre la france en
marche
c'est son choix qu'on a fait et je les
dis avec un certain succès puisque nous
avons obtenu des résultats et qu'en 2007
nous sommes dans une meilleure situation
que l'allemagne donc je crois qu'il faut
bien prendre en compte ces éléments nous
n'avons pas décidé de changer un système
optimal qui fonctionnait parfaitement
et de ce point de vue là je le rappelle
quand j'arrive aux affaires les
dividendes autoroutier c'est 330 2
millions d'euros alors certes gilles de
robien peut penser que c'est ce qui
permet de tout régler et que si on
attendait 5 ou 10 ans on avait une
cagnotte
et ça aussi ça fait rêver les français
mais cinq ou dix ans c'est cette
équation était alors ça soit sur le
magot qui n'existait pas en espérant que
ce magot arriverait un jour et si les
taux d'intérêt n'était pas passée de 4%
à 0
qu'est ce qu'on aurait fait et si les
taux d'intérêt
pacy à 6% alors là oui françois fillon
aurait eu raison de dire ce qu'il a dit
à tort que l'état français était en
faillite à l'été 2007 alors que j'ai
laissé un taux d'endettement de 64 3%
comme je les ai indiqué tout à l'heure
donc vous voyez bien c'est très
compliqué et nous avons voulu avec
thierry breton assumer en conscience une
exigence qui est celle du désendettement
et alors on me dira 1 % de la dette
c'est pas suffisant pour mériter
l'effort que vous avez fait une fois de
plus il n'y avait pas de poule aux oeufs
d'or
quand je suis arrivée aux affaires trois
centres de 332 millions d'euros sur un
budget de la fidh d'un milliard d'euros
qu'est ce que vous faites avec ça ça
veut dire quoi
on le le tgv montpellier rhin-rhône
bordeaux rennes il n'existerait pas
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on ferait
français sont très contents évidemment
qu'ils sont très mécontents de du
recours au tgv
mais beaucoup des français aujourd'hui
considère qu'on a rendu un grand service
à notre pays en développement cet outil
ferroviaire dont je crois qu'il faut se
replacer dans le contexte de l'époque
nous avons arbitré par ce que nous avons
pensé que les marges de manoeuvre que
nous pouvions dégagé était utile alors
que les marges de manoeuvre que nous
avions etc avaient d'ailleurs gilles de
robien comme jean pierre raffarin ils
n'étaient pas en situation du moindre
investissement public dans cette période
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de cagnotte
c'était une cagnotte virtuel quand vous
êtes premier ministre les canaux
virtuels c'est sympathique mais ça ne
nourrit pas son homme mais ça nourrit
pas la france donc voila voila le choix
que nous avons fait nous avons voulu
aller de l'avant merci merci monsieur le
premier ministre jérôme bascher sa
collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur
premier ministre j'ai quelques souvenirs
de cette époque
dans le même temps où vous étiez nommé
premier ministre était en cours
un rapport d'information parlementaire
d'hervé mariton dont vous étiez proche
qui rend ses conclusions je crois le 22
juin quelques jours après votre discours
de politique générale mais qui grosso
modo reprend sans dire explicitement
il faut privatiser un certain nombre des
remarques que vous faites est ce que il
ya une aspiration politique qui est là
sachant que cette mission d'information
n'est pas là totalement au hasard après
justement l'échec qu'a rappelé gilles de
robien et que vous venez de rappeler de
plusieurs tentatives de privatisation et
donc n'était ce pas là quelque chose à
dire d'un peut commander qui arrangeait
certaines affaires parce que c'est une
question simple à laquelle vous avez
tout en maintenant riez ils répondent
par oui ou par non
est ce que cette décision n'était pas en
vérité purement budgétaire vous parlez
de la vision qu'on a prise et non et non
monsieur le sénateur je viens d'essayer
de l'expliquer elle était stratégique
c'est à dire que pour une part
budgétaire mais est ce que faire des
lignes à grande vitesse
c'est du budgétaire non est-ce que
désendetter c'est faire du budgétaire
c'est tout simplement rappeler aux
français ce qu'on va leur rappeler dans
les cinq ans et les 10 ans à venir à
partir d'une france qui va connaître un
tsunami économique et financier on va
leur rappeler tout simplement qu'on ne
peut pas faire n'importe quoi
nous sommes il faut bien le comprendre
et c'est pour cela que j'ai parlé de
chronos centrisme nous sommes dans une
situation de totale l'anomalie vous
comprenez des taux zéro de l'argent qui
coule à flot et qui ne coûte rien avec
les français qui ont le sentiment qu'on
peut tout faire tout se permettre
ad vitam aeternam mais c'est une
situation ubuesque qui ne durera pas
donc oui j'ai été un premier ministre
qui avait les pieds sur terre qui a
respecté une certaine pesanteur
budgétaires économiques et politiques
qui a fait preuve de responsabilité
c'est parfois plus simple
de surfer sur la vague et de dépenser un
argent qu'on n'a pas c'est pas l'idée
que je me fais de l'état donc oui de ce
point de vue là il y avait une exigence
et une politique qui a été celle de la
rigueur j'hésitais raymond barre tout à
l'heure ce n'est pas un hasard si c'est
la deuxième fois dans l'histoire de
l'état des dernières décennies que dans
cette période 2005-2007
la dette de l'état a diminué donc
uniquement budgétaire certainement pas
puisque nous avons relancé dans cette
période la croissance ne l'oublié pas
nous menions la bataille de l'emploi
la bataille de l'emploi et c'est là il
faut faire un tout petit peu d'économie
et de stratégie la bataille de l'emploi
c'est des entreprises qui créent des
emplois
parce qu'elles ont des perspectives donc
il ne s'agissait pas uniquement
d'appliquer une règle budgétaire comme
on applique un couperet il s'agissait
d'avoir une vision et de renforcer
l'économie française par ailleurs on se
plaint tous les jours aujourd'hui en
france ne plus avoir d'industrie on se
plaint de ne pas avoir de champion
industriel français et européen est bien
à travers la politique que j'ai menée à
l'époque avec jacques chirac agences de
compétitivité pôles de compétitivité
agence d'innovation industrielle
nous avons fait en sorte patriotisme
économique nous avons fait en sorte de
défendre l'industrie française de
constituer des champions nationaux et
européens capables de rivaliser dans les
appels d'offres européens
c'est ça qui fait l'économie d'une
nation alors une fois de plus nous
sommes dans une période et je le dis
avec beaucoup de tristesse
nous sommes dans une période déboussolés
nous sommes dans une période où on dit
et on fait souvent trop souvent
n'importe quoi alors oui ça peut
paraître incongru qu'à l'époque un
premier ministre un président de la
république un ministre des finances un
ministre des transports et pris des
décisions fondées sur des exigences
donc oui il y avait des exigences y
compris budgétaire oui il y avait une
volonté de rigueur mais oui et surtout
oui il y avait une vision
merci le premier ministre notre collègue
sénatrice michèle vullien va vous poser
sa ou ses questions
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
merci et merci pour ce jeu plaidoyer que
vous venez de faire parce que on n'est
pas là en train de juger la politique
que vous avez souhaité mener à cette
époque on est en train d'essayer de
comprendre comment on en arrive
finalement par toute une succession et
j'entends parfaitement ce que vous dites
sur on ne juge pas par rapport à
l'époque ça vraiment vous soyez soyez
sans crainte mais en revanche on est en
train de se poser la question comment on
en est arrivé au fait que finalement les
sociétés concessionnaires et bien sont
loin d'être perdante
et comment on peut dans l'avenir et je
crois que monsieur le rapporteur a posé
la question comment faut-il réfléchir
pour l'avenir quand on va arriver à la
fin des concessions ces concessions qui
au fil du temps on était tellement
projet de fois tellement avait il ya eu
des adossements il ya eu et c'est
comment on peut j'allais dire arrêtez
cette mécanique quand légalement cela va
arriver à terme et comment on peut
imaginer que l'état reprenne la main
tout ou partie sur en réfléchissant sur
d'autres formes que les concessions des
régie intéressée ou ou autre votre point
de vue là-dessus avec le temps qui s'est
écoulé avec la situation actuelle et
comme vous venez de le dire
situation un peu déboussolés par
différentes choses
on est là sur une pandémie qui n'est pas
fini on est à la veille
on est neuf le disent on est sensé que
tout va bien aller d'un point de vue
sanitaire
or on voit que des clusters sont en
train de redémarrer que des pays referme
leurs frontières
donc je pense qu'effectivement on est
dans une période très très très complexe
mais comment pourrait-on imaginer qu'à
la fin des concessions sans continuer de
le mettre six en six ans
les a doucement c'est terminé qu'est ce
que vous préconisez auriez si vous étiez
actuellement aux manettes
merci infiniment madame la sénatrice je
crois que vous avez raison
[Musique]
la grande question c'est de se tourner
vers l'avenir vous évoquez la situation
florissante des sociétés d'autoroutes je
crois qu'il faut essayer de bien mesurer
la situation et de bien rappeler les
choses d'abord c'est vrai que on a fait
un procès d'intention sociétés
d'autoroutes au départ avec des
dividendes versés de 2006 à 2013 qui
était tout à fait considérable mais
n'oublions pas qu'elle est le schéma
quel est le modèle de la concession
c'est un modèle qui se fait à travers
trois périodes
il ya en particulier une période qu'on a
tendance à oublier
aujourd'hui et qu'on a oublié
certainement dans la première étape
c'est qu'il ya une période où est ce
qu'ils ne te route doivent restituer les
infrastructures pour jallet même pas
dire un franc symbolique ou un euro
symbolique le restitue pour 0 troc
il faut bien voir qu'il ya une une vie
une naissance une vie et puis et puis
mort pour les sociétés d'autoroutes à un
moment donné et je crois qu'il faut donc
comparer ce qui est comparable et en
particulier rappelé qu'à l'échéance des
contrats pour les sociétés d'autoroutes
il leur faudra d'abord amortir les fonds
propres
on a estimé c'est le chiffre n'est
couramment données de 24 milliards
d'euros
il faudra régler l'intégralité de la
dette des sociétés concessionnaires qui
est estimé de l'ordre de 18 milliards
d'euros et les investissements de
renouvellement et de modernisation de
l'ordre de 26 milliards d'euros
enfin il faudra rémunérer le capital qui
a été investi car je les dis au terme il
faudra restituer les infrastructures ce
qui en cumulant rien qu'en cumulant la
valeur des fonds propres représente 70
milliards d'euros donc une fois de plus
on a le sentiment que ce qu'était la
poule aux oeufs d'or a été transféré de
l'état aux sociétés d'autoroutes
il faut prendre en compte ce modèle qui
est un modèle
particulier et je ne crois pas que ce
soit les péages qui ont fait augmenter
la valeur des concessionnaires donc on
ne peut pas imaginer que l'état tout
seul aurait réussi à lui-même s'arroger
cette manne financière
il faut prendre en compte les deux
variables sur lequel agissent
aujourd'hui les sociétés d'autoroutes
d'abord le niveau des taux d'intérêt et
je pense que s'il ya un enrichissement
que certains qualifient sans cause des
sociétés d'autoroute c'est dû en grande
partie parce que c'est un modèle
financier qu'ils ont mis au point en
grande partie en raison des taux
d'intérêt bas est ce que l'état aurait
pu profiter de ces taux d'intérêt bas ce
n'est pas du tout quelque chose
d'évident je rappelle que la fuite ne
peut pas se départir des règles de
maastricht et certainement pas s'amuser
à faire de l'ingénierie financière comme
le font des sociétés privées
deuxièmement la seconde variable c'est
le trafic est depuis 2006 le secteur
routier autoroutier a fait face à deux
crises la crise de 2008
bien sûr et la nouvelle crise sanitaire
de 2020 donc vraisemblablement est ce
que les sociétés d'autoroutes ont le
même potentiel de croissance dans les
prochaines années
est ce que la question de cette cagnotte
de cette manne financière sur laquelle
on voudrait remettre la main est-ce que
ça se pose en ces termes je crains pense
qu'il y à bien des égards des illusions
ce point de vue donc la vraie question
pour répondre à ce que vous avez posé
qui me paraît fondamental que faire dans
l'avenir
je crois que dans l'avenir il faut
s'assurer que nous mettons en place un
système où toutes les garanties sont
rice garantie de durer avec clause de
rendez vous avec la possible de la
possibilité pour l'état mais ça existe
on cite toujours l'arrêt du conseil
d'état commune de l'hiver 2009 qui
permet en cas de de rentabilité
excessive de reprendre la main et il y à
d'autres clauses il y avait des clauses
dans les cahiers des charges que nous
avons fait remettre en 2006 qui
permettait d'éviter aussi certains abus
donc je crois qu'il ya une garantie qui
doit être trouvé sur la durée et le
rendez-vous et puis il faudra lors de la
vraie renégociation des contrats quand
ce sera possible en fin de concession
et de ce point de vue là je regrette je
le redis que l'on est allongé par trop
ces concessions parce que c'est bien
quand il y aura ce rendez vous et je le
redis ce rendez-vous malheureusement
n'était pas possible en 2005 2006
contrairement à ce que beaucoup disent
en tout cas il n'était pas si simple
en 2005-2006 et donc je crois que c'est
les deux éléments sur lequel il faut se
fonder retrouver la main sur la durée et
les durées longues dans un état moderne
dans la mondialisation où les imprévus
sont nombreux sont très dangereux donc
je crois qu'un il ne faut pas allonger
la durée
2 il ne faut pas abandonner les péages
je crois que c'est un modèle qui est en
question aujourd'hui nous voyons bien
que la question de l'acceptabilité des
péages et posé il ya un ras-le-bol des
français devant un système qui y compris
dans ce qui est aujourd'hui les trajets
du quotidien pose question néanmoins
c'est un principe qui fonde aujourd'hui
l'équilibré du système
il faut réparer et préparer un nouveau
modèle et il faut et ça c'est un élément
clé bien choisir de remettre en
concurrence
l'ensemble des sociétés avant la
réattribution donc je crois qu'en
respectant ces quatre règles on a de
quoi recalé le système autoroutier
alors est-ce qu'il faut imaginer la
nationalisation des autoroutes reprendre
la main régis que j'entends ici et là
enfin écoutez si l'état n'arrive pas à
faire les moindres travaux et si il a
payé
parfois son détriment très cher en
allongement de durée pour faire faire
par les sociétés d'études d'autoroute
des travaux que il aurait peut-être pu
faire lui-même c'est bien parce que nous
n'avons pas les moyens aujourd'hui il
faut bien voir la réalité des choses
l'état est dans une situation financière
ou l'idée de reprendre la main me paraît
sauf retour à la vertu qui n'est pas
dans l'esprit du jour très honnêtement
sympathique mais un peu un peu ubuesque
merci je crois que les échos et
sénateurs dont plus de questions à poser
mais je sais que le rapporteur lui reste
quelques unes ouvrir rapidement monsieur
pour les nordistes n'ont pas pour
prolonger trop cette audition mais en
tout cas est très intéressante et puis
je redis vous avez très bien préparer
votre votre sujet vous défendez très
bien des prises de position que vous
avez eu à prendre au partage d'ailleurs
dans votre existence bons souhaits
d'exigence et de rigueur
en tout cas que vous avez largement
démontré de deux questions
complémentaires à ses cours p sur sur la
transparence parce que effectivement il
ya nécessité de transparence qui
visiblement n'a pas toujours été de mise
en matière de concessions autoroutières
vous dites que
monsieur perben à l'époque communiste
des transports avait intégré ces
éléments là dans les dents les exigences
vis-à-vis des sociétés concessionnaires
vous dites que ça n'a pas été mise en
oeuvre
ensuite est-ce que à votre avis quelles
sont les raisons pour lesquelles le
concédant donc les services de l'état
n'ont pas réussi à mettre en deux sets
transparence et et cette clarté parce
que finalement c'est ce qu'on cherche on
cherche à avoir une clarté on dit pas
quand on a des contrats il faut que ça
soit ça tous soient sur la table qu'on
comprenne bien
on peut avoir des débats mais des débats
sur des choses claires et passer des
débats sur des choses qu'on ne maîtrise
pas très bien je pense que notre
commission denquête elle va permettre
aussi un peu d'assurés cette clarté mais
pourquoi finalement ça n'a pas pu être
mises en oeuvre
et puis juste une petite question
vous parlez de clause de rendez-vous
nous pensons aussi que sera contrat
longue durée il faut des clauses de
rendez vous et la fréquence de ces
clauses de rendez vous selon vous c'est
ce serait cela qu'elle serait la plus
optimale merci lorsqu'il rappelle qu'en
général je crois que c'est un élément
effectivement important que de renforcer
la main de l'état je prends un exemple
de ce qui avait été décidé en 2006 nous
avions prévu que le commissaire du
gouvernement puisse participer au
conseil d'administration
or depuis cette date le commissaire de
gouvernement pratique une politique de
chaise vide dans les conseils des
concessionnaires
ça montre quoi ça montre que la question
des autoroutes et du rapport avec le
concessionnaire est traitée à un échelon
technique et pas comme cela devrait être
le cas avec une vision vous ne dit pas
politique mais stratégique
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que le
commissaire du gouvernement qui
participeraient à des conseils
d'administration il doit bien sûr être
informé au préalable il doit bien sûr
avoir des instructions de son cabinet et
voir d'au-dessus de son ministre c'est
un travail de coordination et de
préparation qui est lourd et difficile
mais c'est ça le travail de l'état
et c'est ça qui a fait défaut je ne veux
pas taper sur un état que j'ai servi
pendant des décennies je suis moi même
fonctionnaires et j'ai un immense
respect pour l'état mais c'est vrai que
beaucoup de choses se sont délitées
c'est vrai que beaucoup de choses qui
sont dans la main de l'état ne sont pas
faites avec suffisamment d'exigence et
donc quand on reprend les clauses
contractuelles qui avait été décidée par
exemple l'augmentation du montant des
pénalités de retard et d'exploitation du
par le concessionnaire en cas de
manquement à l'une de ces obligations au
titre du cahier des charges compensation
du gain éventuel les liée à un décalage
dans le temps des travaux prévus quand
on écoute ségolène royal et ce qui s'est
passé en 2015 on voit bien que l'état
n'a pas fait son boulot et ça je le
regrette évidemment parce que je crois
que c'est pas faute d'avoir la capacité
en tout cas juridique de le faire c'est
parce que cette question des autoroutes
et une immense questions politiques dans
notre pays
ils sont calmes et et je vais essayer
d'expliquer pourquoi
c'est une immense questions politiques
d'ailleurs depuis que j'ai quitté
matignon je les bienvenus il ya une
bataille des autoroutes en france
alors c'est peut-être pas l'équivalent
de la bataille sur le voile à l'école
c'est peut-être pas l'équivalent
du prix de l'essence ou de la question
et des trimestre des cotisations
retraite et c'est une bataille sur le
plan symbolique
quand on voit la sphère des gilets
jaunes on voit bien que ce sont des
choses qu'il faut prendre au sérieux
or cette bataille des autoroutes elle
est le résultat de la pression de trois
circonstances que nous devons
constamment avoir en tête la première
c'est un enjeu de proximité parce que
c'est quelque chose de vécu par tous les
français
c'est un enjeu global dans lesquels on
retrouve toutes les problématiques qui
sont au goût du jour aujourd'hui
problématique environnementale sociale
économique politique c'est une question
concrète sur laquelle viennent se
cristalliser tous les débats politiques
enfin c'est un enjeu de long terme parce
que c'est un enjeu qui montre
l'évolution de nos sociétés et de nos
économies
question des taux d'intérêts rôle de la
voiture dans nos sociétés donc c'est
quelque chose qui véritablement créer
une cristallisation importante
voilà pour cette audition de dominique
de villepin